خيارات مواجهه التوسع النووي الايراني في
ظل تعطل التفاهمات حول الملف النووي موضوع
نقاش عاد الى طاوله الدول الغربيه صحيفه
اشارت الى التواصل امريكي ايراني مباشر
الحديث الرئيسي فيه ملف التبادل الاسرى
لكنه قد يؤدي لفتح المحادثات النوويه
مجدده مؤشرات تقول الصحيفه انها جاءت عبر
اتصالات عده بين المسؤولين الغربيين
ونظرائهم الايرانيين خلال الاشهر الاخيره
بدءا باجتماع اوسلو مارس الماضي بين
مسؤولين فرنسيين والمان وبريطانيين مع علي
باقر المفوض النووي الايراني
ثم لقاءات عده جمعت بين مبعوث الولايات
المتحده الى ايران والسفير طهران لدى
الامم المتحده
الصحيفه اشارت الى ان الغرب يتحرك
بالتوازي مع تزايد المخاوف من توسع
الانشطه النوويه لايران ما قد يؤدي الى
نشوب حرب اقليميه حيث قامت طيران بتخصيب
اليورينيوم الى مستويات ستمكنها من انتاج
مواد كافيه لتصنيع سلاح نووي في اقل من
اسبوعين حسب تصريحات مسؤولين امريكيين
فيما اكد التقديرات الوكاله الدوليه
للطاقه الذريه تضاعف مخزون ايران من
اليورينيوم المخصب لقرابه 23 مره بارتفاع
يقدر بنحو طن وبنسبه تفوق
25% منذ فبراير الماضي
يشكل ضعف الحد المنصوص عليه في اتفاق 2015
التاريخي بين طهران والقوه الدوليه عوده
دول الغربيه للتفكير بالتفاوض مع ايران
رغم توقفهم منذ سبتمبر العام الماضي رده
دبلوماسيون غربيون الى الحاجه لخطه
دبلوماسيه لكبح مخططات طيران النوويه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات وتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات